clocking off time for office workers in
belfast this evening but for how long
northern ireland's devolved government
has told people to work from home if
possible to curb the spread of covet 19.
it probably will impact us yeah
yeah in what way
well just because we're working in the
office at the minute but i mean if we're
toward to work from home then we're
gonna have to follow the rules aren't we
so do you think office workers in
general will listen to the executive and
work from home i think it's up to the
boss it's not really up to us i'm
obviously going to do what my boss tells
me to do but um
so far past like kind of struck locked
down as well my everyone's kind of
vaccinated and
a lot of people are just glad to be
getting on with their lives so i can't
really see too many going back distract
working from home now ministers here
also want people to limit their social
contacts and wear face masks in indoor
or crowded settings it's a reset of the
public health message in northern
ireland which has the highest case rate
in the uk it is really an appeal from
the executive collectively but also from
the health service and those working on
it to just ask the people of northern
ireland to double down in regards to
taking the actions that we know that
works
good hand hygiene good respiratory
hygiene social distance from where
possible and following the additional
guidance
for now hospitality is being spared
further restrictions but the work from
home guidance could cut the customer
base for many businesses well it's
always going to affect us with lunch
time trade you know if the people are in
offices they're not going to come out
for lunch so we're going to take a hit
there
more importantly it's going to you know
affect customer sentiment you know if
it's not safe to go into the office to
work
it's a safe to go out to hospitality
that's our big worry coming into
christmas time
and do you think it's the right thing to
do from a public health point of view
no i don't i think you know once again
a lot of pressure has been put onto
hospitality you know as if we're the bad
boys which we aren't you know and i
think it's a case of the executive
maybe being seen to be doing something
authorities say they want to avoid the
surge being seen and other european
countries but the stark reality is that
the infection rate here is already
similar to that in germany which is now
considering lockdown measures
stephen murphy sky news in belfast